Посла відкликали? -
Володимир Зеленський звільняє Андрія Мельника
Міністерка на березі моря -
Анналена Бербок на Палау
Конфлікт щодо Twitter -
Ілон Маск відмовляється від купівлі Twitter
В ефірі «heute journal»
із Гайнцом Вольфом та Марієттою Сломкою.
Добрий вечір.
Якби хтось провів вуличне опитування в Німеччині
і запитав би, як звати чинного російського
чи американського посла в Берліні,
багато хто, ймовірно, не одразу згадав би ім'я.
Але про Андрія Мельника, безперечно, чули.
Обіймаючи посаду посла України в Німеччині,
з часів нападу на його країну
він досяг такого рівня популярності,
якого дипломати не часто досягають.
Однією з причин є те, що Мельник не поводився
як класичний дипломат.
З одного боку, цим він багато чого досяг:
спонукав до дій німецький уряд, викривав порожні фрази.
З іншого боку, він приголомшив багатьох
і своїми заявами притягував до себе критику.
Сьогодні з'явилася новина про те, що Київ
звільнив його з посади.
Тео Колль, це ж не стало цілковитою несподіванкою?
Можна так сказати.
І в різних контекстах.
Я гадаю, що представникам політичної спільноти Берліну
вже кілька тижнів тому натякали,
що посла можуть змінити.
Впродовж останніх тижнів у пресі
з'являлися перші припущення щодо цього,
які не мали офіційного підтвердження
до сьогоднішнього указу Президента України.
Що обговорюють у Берліні,
яка причина звільнення?
Формально це можна назвати звичайним процесом.
Андрій Мельник перебував на посаді посла в Берліні
майже вдвічі довше,
ніж це заведено,
крім нього звільнилище багато інших українських послів.
Президент України також наголосив на цьому сьогодні ввечері.
Але низка факторів свідчить про те,
що це не є звичайним відкликанням.
Андрій Мельник нещодавно применшив злочини
провідного радикального та антисемітського націоналіста
часів Другої світової війни Степана Бандери,
що викликало хвилю обурення з боку Польщі та Ізраїлю
та лило воду на млин російської пропаганди,
що вже давно стверджує, що Росія бореться в Україні
проти нацистів.
Крім того, у Києві, можливо, змінився погляд
на досить недипломатичну поведінку Мельника.
Спочатку його різка критика німецької нерішучості
справді мала певний політичний та журналістський ефект.
Але після того, як висловлювання Мельника
стали дедалі різкішими, -
як-от, коли він назвав Олафа Шольца
«ображеною ліверною ковбасою», -
уряд в Києві також міг задуматися,
чи не заподіює цей войовничий «недипломат»
дедалі більше шкоди,
ніж приносить користь.
Я думаю, його звільнення - відповідь на це питання.
Дякуємо, Тео, за роз'яснення.
Тим часом Анналена Бербок сьогодні
скористалася можливістю
привернути увагу до питання,
яке не пов'язане з війною, що панує над усім у Європі.
Після зустрічі G20 на Балі вона вирушила до Палау.
Острівна держава з сотнями островів розташована
у західній частині Тихого океану - в Мікронезії.
Хоча серед цих островів є об'єкт Світової спадщини ЮНЕСКО,
жителі Палау бачать наслідки зміни клімату вже щодня.
А сьогодні вони бачили міністерку закордонних справ Німеччини,
яка ходила берегом моря босоніж.
Під час свого перебування на посаді вона справді
хотіла привернути набагато більшу увагу
до цієї світової проблеми,
ніж це вдавалося зробити впродовж останніх місяців.
Детальніше - Андреас Кюнаст.
Леон провів на Палау все своє життя.
Він бачить море та пляж,
який сьогодні обходить та знімає
делегація міністерства Німеччини.
Леон знімає, як німці знімають каміння,
яке він нагромадив, тому що рівень моря з року в рік
стає дедалі вищим.
Каменів замало.
Нам потрібен великий бар'єр,
щоб хвилям не вдавалося
змивати пісок у море.
На березі моря перед будинком Леона стоїть Анналена Бербок.
Це перший за 120 років візит
міністра Німеччини до Палау.
Місцеві жителі підрахували,
що Палау, можливо, так і переживатиме
глобальне потепління на 1,5°.
Але чи вдасться утримати потепління на рівні 1,5°?
19 000 жителів Палау б'ють на сполох вже багато років,
відправляють делегації на всі кліматичні конференції,
надають статистичні дані, графіки, неспростовні факти.
Але я мушу визнати, що наша міжнародна реакція щодо цього
була недостатньою,
наша підтримка була надто обмеженою.
Сьогодні Анналена Бербок пообіцяла підтримку Палау
у розвитку відновлюваних джерел енергії,
щоб жителі островів більше не потребували
дизельних генераторів.
Скільки років, пане Губернаторе, ще існуватиме Палау?
Цікаве запитання.
Ми сподіваємося, що працюватимемо
з вченими-спеціалістами,
які зможуть «подарувати» нам ще одне століття.
До буденних справ Міністерки закордонних справ
з партії Зелених
належить те, що їй доводиться виправдовувати доцільність кожної поїздки,
а тим паче цієї - досить далекої.
Чому ж в ім'я захисту клімату
дозволено летіти на інший кінець світу?
Теоретично про це можна прочитати в газеті.
Але коли ви бачите це на власні очі,
коли у такі делегаційні поїздки
вирушають також і багато журналістів, і парламентаріїв,
тоді, сподіваюся, ці новини поширюватимуться,
бо у цьому разі зрозуміло:
час спливає.
Час, що ще залишився, розподіляється нерівномірно.
У Палау його залишилося менше, ніж у Німеччини.
Перейдемо до обговорення новини економіки,
що сьогодні знову потрапляє в газетні заголовки всього світу,
і впродовж деякого часу вже набула
майже курйозних рис.
Йдеться про дивну поведінку мільярдера Ілона Маска:
«Купувати Twitter чи не купувати?».
Ми вже знаємо, що цей чоловік ексцентричний.
Водночас на нього покладають багато надій,
причому не лише у німецькому Бранденбурзі.
Було безліч припущень щодо того,
чому він хотів будь-що-будь стати власником Twitter,
ще й ﻿за величезною ціною.
Чи мав він політичні мотиви?
Навіщо ж тоді він завдав шкоди своїми зневажливими заявами
репутації компанії, з якою вже підписав
договір купівлі-продажу?
А сьогодні він офіційно розірвав цю угоду.
Докладніше - Анна Файст.
Закриття торгів на фондових біржах Волл-Стріт.
Вечір п'ятниці.
Можливо, розрахунок був саме на те,
щоб оприлюднити інформацію про відмову ﻿Ілона Маска
купувати Twitter лише після закриття.
Бо вже після завершення основної сесії торгів
акції Twitter впали на 6%.
Це спричинить ефект доміно.
Від початку це була справжня мильна опера.
Те, що почалося у квітні із пропозиції у 44 млрд доларів,
зараз має сумнівну кінцівку - Маск зійшов зі сцени.
Мильна опера двома словами:
наприкінці березня Маск планував створити
власну соціальну мережу.
Кілька днів по тому він став найбільшим акціонером Twitter
та розпочав процес поглинання компанії.
Спершу керівництво Twitter чинило цьому опір,
але потім, наприкінці квітня, компанія підписала договір.
Ілон Маск мав купити Twitter за 44 млрд доларів,
тобто 54 долари за акцію.
Через два тижні Ілон Маск раптово загальмував.
Він очікував від Twitter більше даних
про спамерські і фейкові акаунти.
А сьогодні - справжня сенсація.
Маск оголошує про розірвання угоди.
Яка причина?
Він, напевно, зрозумів, що заплатив за компанію надто багато.
54 долари за акцію - це надто багато.
Тому він шукає виправдання, щоб викрутитись.
Чи вдасться йому уникнути покарання у суді?
Малоймовірно, що суд ухвалить рішення,
що Маск може відмовитися від підписаного контракту.
Маск поки що не дав жодних додаткових коментарів,
а Twitter також проінструктував своїх співробітників
нічого не публікувати на цю тему.
Однак одне можна сказати точно.
У понеділок Twitter, мабуть,
буде у вільному падінні.
Ми припускаємо 25-30 доларів на відкритті біржі.
Тиск буде великий,
тому що саме Маск підтримував стабільність акцій.
Мильна опера, напевно, продовжиться з понеділка.
Тепер до новин від Гайнца Вольфа.
Президент Шрі-Ланки Раджапакса хоче піти у відставку
після бурхливих протестів у країні.
Відставку очікують у середу.
Прем'єр-міністр також заявив про наміри піти у відставку.
Раніше протестувальники увірвалися до офіційної
резиденції президента.
Вони вважають Раджапаксу та його уряд
винними в одній із найважчих економічних криз
у країні.
Шрі-Ланка в боргах.
Продовольство, пальне і медикаменти - у дефіциті
протягом кількох місяців.
Держсекретар США Блінкен знову закликав
Китай зайняти чітку позицію щодо війни в Україні
та засудити російську агресію.
Після зустрічі зі своїм китайським колегою Ван Ї
в кулуарах конференції G20 на Балі Блінкен сказав,
що це справді момент, «коли потрібно встати,
щоб засудити агресію і вимагати від Росії припинити війну».
У зв'язку із вбивством колишнього глави уряду
Японії Сіндзо Абе
з усього світу надходять слова співчуття.
Черги скорботних утворилися біля лікарні,
де Абе помер від отриманих вогнепальних поранень.
За повідомленнями японських ЗМІ,
убивця зізнався, що діяв з ненависті до релігійної групи,
нібито пов'язаної з Абе.
У Байройті стався напад на місцевого політика.
Ймовірно, йдеться про правих екстремістів.
За даними, чоловік спочатку висловлював расистські образи
політику SPD Халілу Тасделену,
а потім ударив його кулаком в обличчя.
Поліція заарештувала
35-річного підозрюваного.
Зростаюча кількість хворих на коронавірус і багато хворого персоналу
спричиняють навантаження приблизно на половину
відділень інтенсивної терапії в лікарнях Німеччини.
Про це медіаконцерну Funke Mediengruppe розповів президент
Німецької міждисциплінарної асоціації інтенсивної та невідкладної медицини DIVI
Гернот Маркс.
Хоча допомога екстреним пацієнтам забезпечена всюди,
численні операції вже довелося відкласти.
Занепокоєння викликає не лише значне навантаження на лікарні,
але також довгострокові наслідки ковіду для суспільства та
системи охорони здоров'я.
Досі мало достовірних знань
про феномен тривалого ковіду - лонгковід.
Проте зрозуміло, що Sars-Cov2,
як і багато інших вірусних захворювань,
може мати довгострокові наслідки, включаючи тяжкі
хронічні захворювання.
Серед перехворілих є пацієнти, які описували себе до ковіду як
абсолютно здорових, молодих і спортивних людей,
але так і не змогли повністю відновитися
після зараження коронавірусом.
Поки що незрозуміло,
хто саме і скільки людей схильні до лонгковіду.
Всесвітня організація охорони здоров'я вважає,
що не менше ніж у 10% усіх перехворілих
вплив коронавірусу не проходить через два-три тижні.
Лікарі сподіваються на нові ліки,
повідомляє Сібілла Басслер.
Андреас Вінтер у відчаї.
37-річний чоловік двічі заразився коронавірусом.
Він страждає від постковідного синдрому: задишка, запаморочення,
розлади шлунково-кишкового тракта, забудькуватість.
«Кожен день - це якісь муки», каже батько сімейства.
Я не знаю, скільки разів я ходив до різних лікарів,
робив аналізи крові.
Зрештою, лікарі сказали: так, це тривалий ковід.
Але ми не знаємо, чим можемо допомогти.
Нещодавно Вінтер брав участь у дослідженні
університетської клініки в Ерлангені.
Під час детальних обстежень лікарі з'ясовують
причини ﻿його хвороби.
Важливий компонент - аналіз крові.
Клітини крові пацієнтів із ковідними захворюваннями
менш еластичні і,
ймовірно, гірше переносять кисень у кровоносній системи.
Це може пояснити деякі симптоми: задишка, втома, стомлюваність,
тому що еритроцити вже не можуть
пройти через найтонші капіляри
та виконати свою роботу.
Ще одна стадія обстежень - тестування когнітивних здібностей.
Які причини скарг Вінтера?
Чи вірус колись залишав його організм?
Чи викликав він ушкодження органів?
Чи його імунна система божеволіє?
Мета дослідження полягає у тому, щоб зібрати
різні шматочки головоломки з результатів обстежень,
а потім скласти з них цілісну картину
і порадити пацієнтам відповідну терапію.
Що стосується Вінтера: схоже, власні білки організму
атакують його організм.
Не кожен лонгковідний пацієнт страждає від цього.
Чи зупиниться цей процес сам собою - невідомо.
Однак допомогти можуть ліки,
які відключають цей збій.
Такий препарат вже існує - B10 007 і він використовувався
рік тому в Ерлангені
з хорошими результатами,
але препарат досі не схвалений.
Чому ні?
Я вважаю, що цей препарат є дуже перспективним.
Але ми не можемо давати жодних політичних вказівок,
це має бути оцінено медичними асоціаціями.
Справа в тому, що альтернатив практично немає.
Це гірка правда, каже інфекціоніст Клеменс Вендтнер.
Необхідно критично оцінити, чи не було б все таки доцільним
видати надзвичайний дозвіл, в екстреному порядку,
щоб скоротити час лікування пацієнтів під час пандемії.
А Андреас Вінтер?
Для нього це означає бути терплячим, витримати стан відчаю.
Щовечора ви питаєте себе, коли це нарешті закінчиться?
Ви просто хочете жити як раніше.
Андреас Вінтер - один із приблизно 2 млн людей у ​​Німеччині,
які страждають від тривалого ковіду.
Про спорт цієї суботи: Єлена Рибакіна з Казахстану
виграла фінал на тенісному турнірі у Вімблдоні.
Рибакіна програла перший сет, але потім повернула хід матчу
і виграла два наступні сети
в Унс Джабір із Тунісу.
Чемпіон світу з автоперегонів у Формулі-1
Макс Ферстаппен виграв спринтерську гонку в
австрійському Шпільберзі,
випередивши Шарля Леклера та Карлоса Сайнца.
Таким чином, на завтрашній гонці на Гран-прі Австрії
Ферстаппен стартуватиме з поулу.
Виграшні номери лотереї цієї суботи на екрані.
Як завжди, без гарантії.
Інші виграшні номери на сайті lotto.zdf.de
і в текстовій версії zdf на сторінці 557.
Прогноз погоди: завтра переважно сонячно
у регіоні Верхнього Рейну.
На решті території - хмарно, подекуди зливи.
На півночі дме поривчастий північно-західний вітер.
Температура підвищиться до 16-25°.
У понеділок хмарно.
З вівторка - сонячно, температура підвищиться.
У середу 35° на південному заході.
Це всі новини суботнього вечора.
О 00:45 випуск«heute Xpress»
До побачення.